merci la parole est à monsieur yannick
moreau à 300 jours du vote sur le
holland exit je voulais monsieur le
premier ministre vous interroger sur le
bilan de votre gouvernement et sa
passivité à l'égard des occupations
illégales de terrains par un nombre
croissant de groupes de gens du voyage
c'est un fait établi avec l'été les gens
du voyage voyage jusqu'ici tout va bien
mais ce qui est inacceptable c'est que
les communes qui respectent leurs
obligations légales d'accueil se voit
trop souvent confrontés à des
occupations sauvages de terrain en
vendée littoral comme ailleurs on ne
compte plus le nombre de stades de foot
de parcs publics d'aérodrome privatisée
en toute impunité par des groupes de
gens du voyage tout se passe alors comme
si les gens du voyage avaient tous les
droits et les habitants des communes qui
les accueillent le seul droit de subir
et de payer les dégâts
tout se passe comme si certains français
était plus égaux que d'autres
nous députés de droite avant pourtant
soumis une proposition de loi
rééquilibrant les droits et devoirs des
gens du voyage et des collectivités
votre majorité l'a balayée et
responsable aujourd'hui du fait que le
droit en vigueur à l'été 2016 n'est pas
évolué d'un millimètre sur ce sujet
sensible
pourtant les choses sont simples la
liberté de stationnement des gens du
voyage s'arrête là où commence la
propriété des autres monsieur le premier
ministre
donner aux maires les moyens de lutter à
armes juridiques égales contre les
occupations sauvages afin de garantir la
propriété privée la tranquillité
publique et l'ordre donné plus de droits
aux communes et plus de devoirs aux gens
du voyage qui ne respectent pas les
règles il y a urgence monsieur le
premier ministre il ne vous reste que
300 jours pour agir enfin il ne vous
reste que 300 jours pour pacifier les
conditions d'accueil des gens du voyage
il ne vous reste que 300 jours avant le
holland exit jean marie le guen
sac à terre d'état chargé des relations
avec le parlement merci monsieur le
président monsieur je pensais que sur le
député je pensais que cette question
était suffisamment sérieuse pour qu'elle
ne se prête pas une potée d'une
politisation de mauvais aloi et donc je
vais essayer néanmoins de répondre au
fond à votre question
d'abord vous le savez où vous devriez le
savoir
dans le cadre de la loi égalité
citoyenneté le gouvernement a décidé
d'intégrer la proposition de loi de
dominique raimbourg qui traite de cette
question avec beaucoup de justesse elle
le fait parce qu'elle n'a pas pu le
faire plus tôt parce que la droite au
sénat avait refusé d'inscrire cette loi
alors que dit cette proposition de loi
puisque je suis là pour vous informer
elle fait enfin entrer les gens du
voyage dans le droit commun et tourne le
dos à une histoire que vous connaissez
une histoire discriminatoire qui n'avait
pas de raison d'être
c'est donc une avancée importante elle
interdit aussi la discrimination des
enfants en fonction du type d'habitat
lors de l'unss leur inscription à
l'école et enfin monsieur le député elle
donne effectivement de nouveaux droits
pour les mères qui se met en situation
d'être conforme à la loi c'est-à-dire de
prévoir effectivement sur le territoire
de leur commune
la possibilité pour les gens du voyage
de disposer d'un certain nombre de
terrains dans un certain nombre de
conditions je vous le rappelle ça donne
au préfet saisie par ces mères leur
donnera une capacité beaucoup plus
grande d'intervenir d'une façon beaucoup
plus rapide d'une part beaucoup plus
permanente
d'autre part un renforcement des
procédures par ailleurs dans le même
temps vous le savez l'aide au
financement des aires d'accueil par les
communes des communes et des
intercommunalités et renforcée par
l'action de l'état au niveau aussi bien
de la dgf que des
crédit en fonction des territoires
ruraux
voilà monsieur le député d'une façon
précise comment nous agissons de façon
concrète sans stigmatisation sans
populiste sans démagogie ni mais avec
intérêt quand madame annie le houérou